- Well, and congrats.
I mean, you just got a
star on the Walk of Fame.
- [Anthony] Yes I did.
Yes I did.
- Yes you did.
Was it a weird experience
(applauding)
where it wasn't just you
and no one else there?
(laughing)
Yeah look, look, it's
just me laying there.
- Look at that beard game, that's you!
(undecipherable)
It was, it was me and 11 family
members along with staff.
So yeah, it was just
me and 11 other people.
Yeah, but it was exciting.
You know I went to the
Hollywood Performing Arts
Magnet High School, literally
right across the street
from where I got my star on the corner
of Hollywood and Highland.
- That's the coolest part.
- Yeah, so never in a thousand years,
did I think I would be immortalized
on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame with my own star,
walking those streets every day as a kid.
And even as a young adult,
and to get the call a couple
of years ago to say,
"Hey, we'd like to give you this honor."
- Do you still have
moments where you do go,
holy word I shouldn't sound daytime?
Like it's like I know a
lot of talented singers
and the fact that I
got to be where I'm at,
I'm always like, sometimes it hits me
and I'm just like, how
the hell did that happen?
- Yeah, you know my hashtag
on Instagram and Twitter
is #JustAKidFromCompton you know?
And that's what I am.
I was, I still am just a kid from Compton
who had a dream and I get to
live that dream every day.
So yeah, I pinch myself all the time
and I would be remiss if, can
we get that close right there?
My buddies George Lopez
and Cedric the Entertainer,
we all three of us have a star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
And this is our hall of fame--
- [Kelly] Club?
- Club, so we each have
a ring with our star
and the date that we got it.
- It's like your Superbowl ring.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- And I wanna thank my boys for that.
- That is so cool.
I wanna be in a club.
(laughing)
See, I love anything
with everyone's involved
and there's a jacket or anything involved
and everyone's wearing it.
You always caption your posts
"Just a kid from Compton"
Like you were saying, when
did you start dreaming
to be an actor?
Were really young?
- Nine-years-old is--
- [Kelly] Really?
- when it happened for me.
Yeah, and it probably was before then,
but nine-years-old is when
I made the realization
that this is what I was gonna do
with the rest of my life.
- What happened?
- My mother is a horrible actress.
(laughing)
And she was actually in--
- And beats you.
(laughing)
We love your mom right now.
- And she was actually in a production of
"A Raisin in the Sun" at
Compton Community college.
I'm the oldest of four children and me
and my two younger
brothers were in the back
of the theater during rehearsal one day
and I looked up on stage and
saw my mother rehearsing.
And I said "that is what I'm gonna do
"with the rest of my life."
- Oh, that's special.
- It's truly been my calling.
- [Kelly] I think you have
to dream big on order to get it though.
- Exactly, if you don't, if
your dreams don't scare you
you're not dreaming big enough.
- Did you ever have, I
was, I grew up with people,
you know, especially a small town
or just poor community I grew up in,
everybody would be like,
"You're never gonna make it doing that."
- [Anthony] Right.
- Did you have people
doing that all the time?
- All the time.
- Do you smile so big when you're
on that red carpet, smiling?
(laughing)
- [Anthony] I do.
Because I'm not only
smiling for my success
and for those people
who were the naysayers,
but I'm also smiling for those other kids
in Compton who were just kids
from Compton who have dreams.
- Yeah, 'cause you can do it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I love that.